voilà ça s'appelle lost in la mancha
c'est le making of du film inachevé de
terry gilliam avec liliane dont johnny
depp jean rochefort et vanessa paradis
levier l'air est mûr
les clients de ne la regardais pas voulu
tu regardes et puis après je me suis
retourné
encore une toute petite chose minuscule
je voudrais pas qu'on croie que je suis
incapable de faire marcher un cheval aux
papillons il consacrer la moitié de ma
vie ça oui et dans les dents les
catastrophes supplémentaires ce cheval
est mort le lendemain gullit yeux tout
simplement parce que on avait décidé
pour qu'il ait l'air de rossinante de ne
pas lui donner à bouffer pendant trois
mois un bonjour la spa et bonjour le
spleen de rochefort comme ça ça m'a
foutu un coup tu restes humains seraient
régulés vous vous n'avez pas gueuler
chez moi sur ma tête mais je n'ai plus
la force de paix complètement non non je
ne peux plus monter à 6 séries parce que
vous avez un rapport au cheval qui est
très intéressant c'est à dire que vous
avez été mais les tréteaux au monde du
cheval puisque votre grand père avait
une compagnie de fiacre à dinan et ils
vous n'êtes pas bon en fait de montier
pas malgré ça et à l'âge de 30 ans y pas
non plus tout jeune fait cartouches
vous montez à ce moment là sur un cheval
et vous n'entendrez jamais c'est à dire
j'arrête la compétition à 48 ans avaient
alors pourquoi vouliez pas monté sur un
cheval je crois que c'est parce que vous
aviez peur d'avilir lallaoui noble
conquête de l'homme pensé vga c'est le
respect des êtres pas des choses les
êtres et je pensais qu'on n'avait pas le
droit de monter sur le dos d'un animal
ou d'un homme
ouais ça me gênait beaucoup je voulais
courir à côté ouais ça énervait mon
paient un
mais alors c'est pour ça que j'ai
j'ai réussi très tard cette armada 3
dans ce qui est incroyable c'est quand
vous montez sur un cheval à l'âge de 30
ans il ya quelque chose qu'il se
réveille en vous au niveau génétique
quoi parce que drake jeunesse famille
était là dedans
pourquoi vous devenu complètement fou de
cheval mais ça devient pour vous une
passion pratiquement à 50 50 avec le
cinéma enfin mes pieds alors lui une
histoire extraordinaire c'est un jour
jean est à saint lô dans une foire et
puis à un type qui s'approche ma vieille
éleveurs normands hui cheveux comme ça à
gré sous la casquette en tweed un gros
pigeon tout rouge
c'était à saint lô c'était l'avant que
des étalons de l'année mais voilà les
approches de moi et me dit j'ai vu avec
à la télé je vais protéger du cinéma
séries